Give me two minutes and I'm going to
show you how to run ads for free on any
social media platform that you want. All
right, so check this out. You want to
run an ad to something like a free
course, something that teaches your
target audience how to solve a specific
problem for free. And then that free
course is going to lead to what I call a
tripwire product. So after they got the
course for free and you have their phone
number and you have their email so you
can market them later, you move them
over to a landing page where you offer
them something that costs like $3, okay?
Something ridiculous. Another even
bigger course, the more congruent with
this course, the more likely they'll buy
it. So, say you do a free course on
email marketing and then you do a
tripwire product where for $3 they can
buy 30 email templates.
Okay, now they're loving this because
it's two things that they really want.
And then right there, you already make
your money back if your cost per lead,
if your CPL for this thing to acquire
their number and email is $3 or less.
And the way that you do that is by
running really good ads, especially with
a free course. Free course, anything
like that is going to get you a low cost
per lead. And then, so now you break
even. So your ads are completely free.
It doesn't cost you anything because the
info product sale makes up for the
customer acquisition cost and then you
have their phone number and email to
sell them
something else later, a book, a
community, a course. So, this is the
first sale. You can even move them from
the tripwire to a one-time offer. After
the tripwire, you upsell them something
else. Hey, for $33, you could get blah
blah blah. Now, that's that's going to
tank in conversions. uh compared to this
$3, but at least you own their number
and their email to do this or this. But
you make all of your ad money back from
the tripwire. Pay nothing in
advertising.